yes
grammy award winning country star i've
lost track of how many number one songs
you have
that's how damn good you are good to see
you brother
good to see you too so how many is it
now you got another number
10 10. yes you're sort of the mariah
carey
of country aren't you
how's that please explain that well no
she has a lot of number one hits
yeah but it's like you know i got i got
ten like i think florida georgia line
has been
been here at the same time we got like
18.
what about george strait george here
he's got 62.
how many how many number one hits does
george strait have paulie 44.
40. really that's it i thought it was
61. that's it
yeah 45 42. like he's the goat
is he the goat of country oh no
probably the go to catch is probably
johnny cash he's probably
yeah i'll second that yeah i actually
saw george street last night
oh you did yeah like performing
we were uh cutting the uh charlie pride
special for cmt and he was there we
talked for a while yeah
did you ever meet johnny cash no
never got to meet johnny cash yeah i
wish
i wish yeah i wish i would have i i
wasn't
smart enough at the time to understand
how great he was
like yeah that it's weird
there's certain guys like i'm you know i
saw sinatra at the very end
of his career and i i'm glad i did but i
wish i wouldn't have
yep i know exactly what you mean yeah
yeah yeah
well john i mean johnny as as big as he
is i still think he's underrated
i mean i just think he he was the man i
mean i listen to so much songs now and
johnny cash was the man but when he went
to folsom
prison and sang those songs
in front of the inmates and yeah you got
to hear the whole story like that
his label told him if you do this we're
not going to put it out you can't do it
and he told him to basically kiss his
butt and went and made the record and if
it's a classic
did you ever do a cover of johnny cash
oh i do vote
for some pull some prison blues yeah
yeah
all right so uh my masterpiece is uh out
now that's the new single that follows
the uh
most recent number one single beers and
sunshine
yeah yeah absolutely man life is going
good for dairy so right now
see that i just talked about dan you
should i just talked about myself in the
third person you let me do it
once again mariah carey mariah carey
you're a diva you are a diva
i knew it i i don't okay
so i you have a favorite wrestler
i have two very they're tied number one
of course ric flair
and i can't believe mcgluven didn't
mention dusty rhodes and his thing but
the thing is it's all you northern boys
don't realize that dusty rhodes was
probably the second greatest festival of
all time
yeah it's the northern boy but but you
bought the robe
when we were at the jim valvano
celebrity golf event
and i i just remember going wait
you're going to spend that much money on
a road
dude it was almost fifty thousand
dollars man
but it was worth it i still got it so i
close it right now were you
can you go get it yeah be right back
okay all right
so i was there this is when michael
jordan bought a motorcycle
uh who did he let's see roy williams he
bought a motorcycle for roy williams
wife
and i think they still have it but you
start to see people
spending all this money and all of a
sudden they had ric flair's
robe and darius starts bidding
and i go oh my god and then i go
and this is a a match used uh
brilliant not like a house bathroom
oh okay that is a major boy
that that is pretty special
it is that's like elvis it is he was at
the house the other day and i made him
put it on
wait put it on just put it on real quick
all right put it on real quick let's see
so darius has got his
ric flair elvis
all right i'm back okay okay but okay
what was the conversation like when you
went home
with that robe oh well i was single at
the time
there was no conversation because the
funny conversation was
you were there i'm sitting with the
hoodie boys yeah and this other guy's
been with me and i'm turning to those
guys going
y'all got me right cause i'm getting
this wrong
well you guys weren't swimming in money
back then were you
about that time it was starting to rule
oh okay yeah yeah
yeah you're single and you could afford
that
yeah you know and it's the price i got
some great stuff in my sports collection
and that's my prize possession right
there
uh the dolphins uh you're set you're set
on your quarterback by the way
super bowl you became no you became a
you became a rams fan for a little while
this last year when why
but you you you had a friend who was a
rams fan and you became
a rams fan for a little while and i said
wait a minute you're the guy that the
dolphins make you cry and you're a rams
fan
i was i wasn't a fan i was just helping
my friends support the rest oh okay
so you were you were a fan of the fan of
the rams
okay okay now i got it okay because i
didn't know if you jumped ship i didn't
know if you're not a dolphins fan
never man i got to get my tattoo touched
up i'm ready to go
so you're sold on the dolphins all
everything they did
super bowl no you say that every year
but i
the moves we're making i love what
they're doing in the front office i love
coach forest
i love tour you know i think it's gonna
i mean this could be our year
i'm telling you i'm telling you no
look i love the fact that you you never
jumped off the bandwagon
never man it's been we haven't i always
i always say man we haven't won the
super bowl since i was seven
and i'm 54 now
wow that's a long time
47 years bro and by the way we're coming
up on our anniversary
this week at augusta
was the first time we actually crossed
paths
but you guys didn't say anything to me
because you didn't think that i would
know who you guys were
at the time that's a true story we we
were too scared to come and talk to you
because
i think one of us said like let's go and
say hey i was like he's not gonna know
that
where the heck we are man and he's not
gonna care
even now same thing i know yeah i don't
care
yeah i don't care but yeah that was
1994.
yep 94. yeah yeah
um seton you want to play a little uh my
masterpiece there with uh
darius we do that
i would talk up to the vocals if i knew
when the vocals started
but i'm going to guess one of my songs
we're going to start
right here with darius rucker i was born
with a heart with a beat like a rolling
stone
never did i realize where i was supposed
to
belong i never knew
what i was meant to do
i never made sense to me till i made
sense to you
but baby
have you ever done a one-take song
either with hooting the blowfish or
on your in your solo career you mean
like in the studio yeah just one
one one and done uh i have i have
uh but you know i've done it where i
where i did it and then i
did two three more and took the first
one but uh okay okay
yeah i'm you know let's
sing a song and let's move on but do you
remember the song that
you took the first take on
uh i think letter cry was one of the was
was the first take and then we fixed it
up a little bit
uh uh i believe wagon wheel
oh really that was get it out
have you heard from bob dylan yet about
wagon wheel
yeah he sent me a picture of the check
that's not true no not true but i'm sure
was a big number
and you made it a hit and now you got to
sing it the rest of your career
dude i have a motto in my life that i
don't put any sum on my record i'm not
willing to sing for the rest of my life
and that's the prime example i mean if i
sing three songs i have a single wagon
let's take one i got a single actually
you gotta do
wagon wheel and hold my hand the rest of
your life
the rest the rest of your life okay
absolutely
are you ready for this uh this master's
draft
i'm so ready okay are we doing this now
explain to me how we're doing this okay
it's a snake draft
okay who all's in uh all the dance me
gotcha and you um and all right first
i'll let you go first i'll let you go
you sure we can flip
have you already got it set up i'm ready
you go first
all right i'm gonna go with dustin
johnson oh god
all right uh fritzy you're next
i am going to take mr justin thomas
all right mclovin oh i got to go bryson
de chambeau
all right why okay i'll take that back
he's gonna try to hit the ball he's
gonna try to hit the ball over the trees
in augusta yeah
and two if he gets two triples it's over
he's trying to drive the first green
today
go for it if he he better hit it uh
seton you're next john rahm all right
paulie uh it's been a while for this guy
rory mcelroy
all right i'll take uh jordan
spieth and
on the way back down
i'm gonna take
patrick cantley uh
so now it comes back to paulie he's got
one knee but it's pretty good brooks
kepca okay
all right seating o'connor
i'm gonna take colin morikawa
okay mclovin
tony fenow tony
there's no there's no territorial rights
here
because he's a brother uh fritzi
webb simpson all right then you get
another one
oh no no no then darius go i'm going to
take daniel berger
and my man patrick reed okay
you're one of the few people who likes
patrick reed right i do like patrick
he's a friend of mine
but he's got a bad reputation he does
but he's a good dude
he's got a bad reputation i like patrick
every i like patrick but i'm going to
keep
okay you know what then you don't have
to apologize uh who's next
fritzy i'm gonna take bubba watson who
was just on our show oh okay
all right got bubba uh mclovin i'm gonna
take my guy
victor havilland victor in the hoblins
okay
seaton can't believe andrew just stole
victor from me
did anybody take xander schofley xander
schofley is still on the board
welcome to the team xander polyester
uh call him orikawa oh he's gone
he's gone off the board you should lose
a pic yeah okay
you should if that name how could you
miss that all right paulie then you have
to pick last night
um i'm gonna take cameron smith
and uh so then it's paulie and then
that's it
no you got to pick two and then paul oh
okay oh
no i guess you you're right you pick one
and then paul that's right if we're only
doing how many people are we doing
it's three three rounds okay okay
i have my three paulie you have the last
pick here
uh it's been a long time jason day uh
all right we'll explain how how this
works dan now
it's under par strokes
under par you combined all three golfers
okay okay and they got mrs de cut
uh then
how did we well you don't get the under
par
i get what you're saying so it's that
it's uh if all three guys
you know make the cut then you get their
total there is that right see that's
what uh we came up with
yeah yeah i think that i think we had
that yeah that conversation and it's
awesome of uh
darius to uh put up the nature boy robe
as part of the
is that not part of the contest that's
that's not part of the prize i'll take
you to dinner though
i'll take you to dinner and by the way
that dinner can be expensive
when dairy says with you guys it has
been expensive
we the last time you were in new york
and you had a number one hit
and we went to dinner and that dan
ordered
you actually lost money making that
album i think
after after that dinner oh man i loaded
up because i said hey
are we celebrating he goes bleep yeah
and i go
all right so i didn't i didn't look at
the wine list from right to left
i looked at it from left to right and i
just remember
i think we might have been too drunk to
let the price you know the cost impact
us that night
i think it was the next day and you were
like wait wait what the bleep did you
order last night i said
everything
everything yeah it was it was a good
night though we had a blast
uh great to see you glad you're doing
well and uh
the new single is my masterpiece that's
uh follows the uh
record uh tenth number one single beers
and sunshine
oh by the way he was uh named the
southern of the southerner of the year
what what do you get for that
um i got a key to the south
i got a little blurb in southern living
magazine that's
so you're the southerner of the year
i'm the seller of the year i'd like to
thank everybody who voted for me
again uh and by the way
since i had to send you your grammy back
as
has have the grammy's been nice to you
since then
did it help you at all uh actually yeah
i actually won one
so i want another one that you said
about oh okay well i'm glad that i sent
that back
they're all right there now they're all
right there see them right there yeah
they're sitting there
just sitting there wait that's your
night table that's my night table in my
room
they're just sitting under there see why
why couldn't i have kept one in the man
cave
i don't i thought it was great but i
don't know they got some some
some crazy rules i don't know you know
they they when they send it to you you
get a thing that says like they
they still belong to the grammy they
still belong to the grammys so you know
oh okay yeah i just got this panic
uh message from you like dude you got to
send me my grammy back i'm like
what i couldn't believe everybody gonna
stick up with either man you know
and if you don't give me another one
that's okay i got three
you're no george strait no i'm not no
george paint or vince gill i went to
vince gill's house to do something
to work on his album in the studio he
had 34
i was like man what are you doing i'm
like how do you get 34 grammys you know
but yeah he's got him
well you're sort of like me when i go to
bob costa's
house yeah because bob's bob's got like
25
sports emmys like he gives him out at
halloween that's how many
that's how many he has um hey maybe i'll
cross paths with you here soon
i hope so man i miss you all right love
you brother thank you love you
that's uh darius rucker he's uh very
popular